le week-end dernier c'était la grande
finale de danse avec les stars qui a été
remporté par taik
[Applaudissements]
rappelle dale c'est l'émission qui abuse
un peu trop d'effets spéciaux
et où ne comprend pas toujours ce qui
est dit et après tu sors comme ça voilà
pourquoi la des moments où on aimerait
juste et qui plus rien je te vois
également
mais ce qui a surtout fait parler c'est
une nouvelle règle qui a empêché le
public de repêcher l'un des trois
finalistes candidat et dont michaud a
fait les fleurs ils auront tout fait
pour sortir mi chou c'est terrible en
même temps face aux danses endiablées de
tahiti et de bilal michou n'a pas trop
fait de bois
et ni ses followers il les
encouragements de nice cas ont pu
changer la donne
mais bon si michou n'a pas remporté de
trophée il a apparemment trouvé l'amour
crois tu es je me concentre presque à mi
mai un jarret de porc et oui il faut
quoi qu'il a un peu trop écouté les
conseils de jean paul gaultier au cours
de cette saison ainsi frérot fait nous
du sale alors la finale de danse avec
les stars est elle une grande
supercherie
je vais vous simplifier le travail doc
et le monde on modifie les règles d'une
finale bon mais non mais dans quel monde
on modifie la demi-finale qui deviennent
que le jury et des mines le troisième ne
sont pas le choix enfin sachant que
michou et le plus populaire sur les
réseaux dans le voting s'ils ne sortent
pas en troisième c'est mesut özil dans
fais pas oui amy smith avec devient miss
miss méchoui avec eux mais ils arrivent
bilal non c'est vrai procès ce que c'est
que ces règles mais toujours au monopoly
est l'aveu du ballon la rue de la paix à
vos plumes rouges à l'eau ça non
qu'est ce que je dis c'est que dans les
grosses émissions divertissement comme
ça la production maîtrise beaucoup de
choses comme à l'époque de la star ac
comme à l'époque de secret story et en
insérant effectivement des règles de
dernière minute elles vont jouer en
faveur ou en défaveur de certains
candidats on n'a jamais rien fait dans
secret story
n'ont jamais rien ils ont diamant star
ac ont même laissé plein ils ont essayé
de virer magalie vaé plein de fois on
parle ici c'est vrai que rim et de
maîtrise de la production